can you describe a bit about what's  going on in Europe in regards to energy  sure so Europe is in the worst energy  crisis at least in 50 years but maybe in  its entire history it made a decision 10  20 years ago that they were going to  reduce their Reliance on nuclear power  plants also on coal plants and they were  going to rely more on natural gas  imported from Russia and more on solar  panels and wind turbines mostly imported  from China and so what we saw is that  Europe produced three times more natural  gas than Russia did 15 years ago but  those numbers totally changed and so  Europe now has become completely  dependent on Russia for natural gas  there was already an energy crisis last  year that was brewing but it has  worsened now because Russia and  retaliation for Europe's support of  Ukraine has basically cut off almost all  natural gas to Europe and the continent  is supposed to shut off its petroleum or  oil imports as well